you don't have these problems with
daughters like I don't have that problem
like my daughter challenged me to a
fight
the only problem I ever had with my
daughter is that she's been smarter than
me since she was six and like at the
time when we're sitting in our living
room I didn't understand a word that was
coming out of her mouth like we need my
living in my bed look what's up baby
she's like it's like having a [ __ ]
dolphin in my living room right she
tells me everything - she came home one
day she was like oh my god that he say
something so important oh my god okay
daddy my good buddy okay today I'm gonna
go let me go today am i good today
am I good come on Chris tried to kiss me
and I was like oh my god
I said what happened baby she said oh my
god Eddie I told him I wasn't sure if I
was allowed to do that I had to go home
and ask my daddy and I said you know
what babe thank you very much for asking
look I know you're a teenager and your
hormones are running crazy and and you
don't know what do you know you it's
hard a hard time you know and the
hormones are up and they're down and
look I know it's a hard time and I'm not
going to tell you what to do with what
not to do cuz I don't think that's my
job as your father my job as your father
is just to tell you what I know and what
I know is is that God doesn't let little
hookers into heaven
[Applause]
do whatever you want to do that
information back she's hanging around
teenage boys these boys are the single
biggest predator that walk this planet
Earth they're not in control of what's
happening here it's not there any man
any guy in here will tell you things
used to pop up all the time for no
apparent reason and it was confusing to
us I remember sitting in math class like
and the teacher always thought I was
cheating I was just checking to see if
anybody else was hard I'm like I guess
nobody likes geometry as much as I do
[Applause]
teacher was like mr. wolf
you can leave math class is over no I
can't
picked a bad day to wear sweatpants is
all I'm gonna tell you me and the chick
who just got her period for the first
time we're gonna hang out here for a
little while you don't mind it terrible
I'll tell you some but my daughter man
you learned really early on with her she
is a ride-or-die person if you are on
her team she is on your team for ever
here's what I knew there was no snitch
in her when I met my wife I was a single
and I was raising three kids right and
in my deal she and I had both decided we
were like look it's not important for
her to meet the kids until we know we're
gonna get married because neither one of
us thought it was good for her to start
a relationship with them until we knew
it was a forever raising relationship
for us right so she used to come over
after the kids went to sleep and then
she would go home so one night it's late
and she says to me I don't I can't
really drive home tonight I'm too tired
and I was like well babe the first time
the kids meet you can't be tomorrow
morning in my bed that is not okay she
said I know but I don't know what to do
and I said would you want me to get you
a car and then I'll get your car back
here tomorrow and you can drive a car
home she said I'm just so tired she said
do you mind if I just sleep in your
closet and I was like so let me just see
if I got this right you're coming over
and we're dinner we're gonna have sex
and then you're gonna sleep in the
closet she was like yeah and I go okay
yeah but so she goes to sleep in the
closet next morning I'm up and my deal
with the kids was I make breakfast I
make lunch you get yourselves dressed so
my daughter runs in and I'm cooking
breakfast and she goes daddy I can't
find my shoes and I go babe
you know I'm making breakfast I can't
help ya and she goes I don't know where
I looked everywhere and I said you
didn't look everywhere go find the shoes
so about three minutes later she runs in
and she goes yeah I still can't find my
shoes and there's a stranger sleeping in
your closet and I go okay then thank you
I said I'll help you find your shoes and
she goes okay I go just out of curiosity
Katie there's a stranger sleeping in my
closet that's the reaction I get and on
our way out of the kitchen she goes
it's your closet daddy I don't know what
happens in your brother when I was like
normal carries a body with that girl
[Applause]
[Music]
you